okay alex the show is out in the world
how do you feel are you reading the
comments how are you receiving the
feedback from the audience so far i'm
receiving the positive feedback really
really well not so much the negative
it's just been a whirlwind of emotions
and it's been a roller coaster up and
down up and down up and down so and i'm
sure as people continue to binge it'll
be up and down up and down
there is this kind of split conversation
happening is alex hall the villain or
are jarvis and rose the villain how do
you feel about that conversation it's
interesting because we were able to
watch the show a couple of weeks ago
there was never a debate on whether or
not like i'm the villain or they're the
villain because we all know the
backstory and our reasonings and our
intentions and so to see it fold you
know unfold that way with the viewers
it's shocking it's honestly just
shocking but i can promise you that
there is valid reasoning for our
feelings towards certain people not even
involved in this conversation
so butt out
our time's involved we're sitting here
listening to them why are you sitting
here girl
jarvis and rose weren't even original
cast on the show and so a lot of me
saying why are you here is not to be
rude and not that they don't deserve to
be there of course they deserve to be in
the office they're top producers no
disrespect there we're filming why are
you here because production has informed
us multiple times you're not passed
they've reassured us they're not cast
don't worry that's why i'm always
continually saying why are they here why
are they here why they were like we're
gonna do whatever we've got to do
because we want to be on show and they
saw an opportunity and they took it and
unfortunately
it's just yeah you saw how it all aired
out so oh we're not in a corner look at
where we are is what you always do why
do you speak for her
you're just like
you're ruining everyone's fun watching
it what surprised you most in how it was
all put together and probably how often
so many people are talking about me it
was like alex
alex i'm like oh my god like how do so
many people have so much to say about me
when i have such little interaction with
so many of these people that is what
blew me away the most well while i was
watching i took notes on what was said
about you and i broke it down by who
said it and i want to get your
bullet point response to these so we'll
start with geo and the kind of bizarre
you offended my wife moment
tiffany mentioned that at the grand
opening party when you like came in that
she
went to give you a big hug and went to
say hello and you kind of like just
ignored her
everybody looks incredible
is there more to that story are we
missing something geo and i are we're
good we get it geo understood the
assignment from day one he was there he
was gonna put on a show so even geo and
i had talked about that after and he was
like what the heck like after we saw the
show jio was like what the hell it
looked like she snubbed you and i was
like yeah because you got too caught up
in the fake reality like it didn't
happen like you were looking for a
moment to happen instead of just living
in the moment exactly he also says that
you're threatened by him personally and
professionally i mean no of course not
no he calls you an atomic bomb who blows
things out of proportion it's almost
like i feel like i'm getting gaslit a
little bit in these conversations with
him because but if you actually listen
to what i'm saying i don't think that
i'm blowing anything out of proportion
i'm passionate i'm very passionate and
especially when i feel like something's
being misconstrued or somebody's trying
to
spill false accusations and he says he
would only work with you if he was
supremely desperate
on to the things jarvis said she says
you love to run your mouth i do i love
to talk i love to run my mouth true yes
i do i love to talk i love you know
we're on a reality show they casted us
all individually for a reason and it's
not that i love to hear the sound of my
own voice i know that's just an
expression but i have the gift of gab
she says you're a diva and desperate to
be the center of attention false i think
i command attention i don't think that i
seek to be the center of attention i
think that that is just part of me and
my personality and what i attract it's
not intentional and she labeled you a
bully i beg to differ that term does get
and i'm guilty of it too it does get
thrown around so much but when i refer
to jarvis and rose as bullies it's
because they come in with the intention
of calling somebody out or shaming
and they corner you they put you in this
corner and a lot of it is it's very
irritating because jarvis and rose
aren't a part of like our the other kind
of side of the office like me and napoli
and tyler and austin and brandy so they
don't know what's actually going on they
just come in and they get the snid bits
from production like hey talk about this
and it's like ugh why are you talking
about this you don't know the story you
weren't there so yeah frustrating and
then rose labeled you a snake yeah not
surprised i mean she's a snake the
they're they're the snakes they're the
ones who back story they steal listings
from people they go they listen to your
phone calls in the office and they hear
what properties you're talking about and
then they'll go and door knock on those
properties that's a snake okay i say it
how it is i'm direct i always have pure
intentions and just because i'm loud and
outspoken and opinionated and passionate
does not mean i'm a snake it's very very
different i'm not sneaky do you have any
want need or hope any sort of friendship
with those two or is it kind of like
they are dead to you so in the very
beginning i always give everybody the
benefit of the doubt right innocent
until proven guilty i gave them an
opportunity and i wanted to be friends
and cordial and i had nothing against
them but after seeing the show and
seeing just the rabbit hole that they
went down just to try to get air time
and we're not aligned in that regard i
just really don't i mean i wish them the
best in success and whatnot but our
morals and our personalities probably
just don't align and then in the middle
here is kayla who tells them she feels
betrayed by you how do you feel about
that kind of flip-flop that happened
there's consequences to your actions
obviously the whole tyler thing her
trying to lure him into her car at the
end of every night and that whole thing
was very very unsettling to me and it
put a huge
rift in our work relationship
unfortunately i don't think that i
betrayed her i think up until the very
end i was helpful and i gave her you
know i gave her everything that i had
but at the end of the day she
seemingly is the just the type of person
that is going to hear what she wants to
hear and she starts out hating jefferson
rose then throughout she likes them then
she hates them again then she likes them
again it's like at least we're
consistent
did it surprise you to hear her client
on the co listing say that you're
aggressive and a car salesman he doesn't
like alex at all
why
he said
in his words she's very aggressive and
she comes off like a car salesman oh my
god i mean that was like out of all the
things on the season that was like a
dagger through my heart because i've
never i'm one of the the most seasoned
agents in the office and i've been
working real estate longer than i think
maybe all everybody in the office and
there's also a backstory to that too
with that client of ours kayla had a
prior relationship with him she was
going out to dinners with him and he was
wanting to take her out and i came in
and i said listen you're going to do
what you want to do but my professional
opinion is don't mix business with
pleasure until after business is closed
if you want to go out with him and you
like him he's a nice guy fine but do it
once we close out sell the house first
tell the house first so you're taken
seriously and i came in and i put a
damper on his whole play right and he
was like well who the hell is this and
he was thinking i kind of want to date
you and i'm giving you my listing and i
don't think he liked me because i was
business and kayla listened and she did
put a stop to going out with him and the
extracurricular activities if you will
and when she started doing that he made
a complete 180. then i want to raise the
price that's what he said put 300 extra
on this
okay 100 we brought up the tyler
situation which you are thrown into
because jarvis and rose suggest you are
into tyler as well oh did they okay yeah
what is your reaction to kind of the
conversation around the tyler of it all
and can you explain the noses because to
be honest i had never seen that before
you're you know not alone in that most
people have never seen that before so a
nosey is it's not a sexual act
whatsoever my it started with my mom
doing it to our family dog if you will
this is how disgusting it is and then it
graduated to doing it to us her children
now i do it to my kids it's just a funny
thing to do and we're silly it's nothing
sexual it's nothing crossing the line
and it's where you blow air you put your
mouth over someone's entire nose and you
blow air into their neck it's like a wet
willie on steroids exactly yeah it's
gross like you're not like oh i'm i want
to [ __ ] you let me put my wet finger in
your ear no you're like ooh it's teasing
it's just like a tz type thing the irony
there is that jarvis wasn't at the beach
when that happened i mean it happened
multiple times it wasn't just at the
beach we have a couple of drinks we just
started we're we're silly i have no
interest in tyler whatsoever i adore him
i think he is the sweetest thing and
that the difference there between what i
had done and what kayla had done which
was not try to kiss tyler she tried to
have sex with him on multiple occasions
and made him very uncomfortable and he
had asked her to stop multiple times she
didn't she continued and with our
situation to me there's just no
comparison tyler and i have a
relationship like we're friends kayla
and tyler are not friends they're
colleagues and castmates so it's a very
different i mean anyone who gets it gets
it and if you don't i don't even know
with me trying to explain it we'll get
it looking back at the season that was
is there anything you would have done
differently any regrets you have from
season one of selling the oc i just wish
that there was a little bit more context
to a lot of the scenes like the beach
scene with geo he had continually tried
to start drama with me prior to that on
other like grasping at straws so i was
just like fed up and i wanted to draw
the line in the sand and say listen
don't quit this is done and obviously
alcohol was involved so that but i have
that's i wouldn't have changed it i just
wish that you guys would be able to see
a little bit more of the details behind
some of the scenes well hopefully this
interview kind of fills in a lot of
those gaps for the people what's the
biggest lesson you're walking away with
from this first go-around that you'll
apply should a season two come around
it's not a lesson but i just want to
continue to remember that this is a show
it's a reality show and things are gonna
be skewed and at the end of the day the
best we can hope for is to put out a
good show i am trying to catapult my
career and my business to secure a
future for my children and so that's
really the ultimate goal the lesson is
just continuing i guess to be myself and
remember that it's a show and try to
leave the show where the show is and not
bring it home with me season two likely
gonna happen what is on your wish list
for season two what would you like to
show or do or see happen i hope that the
characters develop and i hope that you
guys can see the depth and the layers
into all of the other characters
including myself including paulie and
brandy and jarvis and rose and and kayla
and i think that time will tell and
eventually you know they can't play the
poker face forever
[Music]
you